one last thing before we go
and and uh the news broke yesterday
during the show i opened pft live on the
radio side talking about this the mike
thomas 100 million dollar contract five
years 100 million and chris i believed
that it was down to the saints wanting
to pay five years 95 million and thomas
wanting five years 100 million it gets
reported as five years 100 million and
then within an hour or so after the show
somebody called me said this is not a
100 million dollar contract it's
96.25 million thomas has to do some
pretty significant things to make the
extra 3.75 million to make it a 100
million dollar deal but chris it was re
this happens all the time the reporters
get the information they don't ask
questions they just rush to twitter with
it and you know what as i said during
pft live on the radio side
in this case one of the reporters that
put it out there and i'm not going to
say who
knew that it was false and still put it
out there and that just it's look i mean
i i think one of the things you and i
are both committed to at all times is
honesty and transparency with the
audience and i don't want to stand up
here and say we deserve a medal or a
ribbon i just think it's presumed if
you're going to be in this business you
have to have a basic level of honesty
and truthfulness and transparency with
your audience and i i and i know we're
not talking about a huge difference here
but there is a mental
impact of 100 whoa it's 100 million
96.25 isn't 100. it's why they sell
things for 5.99 instead of six dollars
there's something about getting up to
that higher number and mike thomas
wanted that higher number and the higher
number as we learned after we spent time
talking about it yesterday the higher
number is not the true number no i mean
it's not it's it's you know agent
propaganda and propaganda it's nfl
propaganda hey whenever it comes to
these contracts and i'm very happy that
michael thomas got his money good for
him that's awesome life-changing moment
he's worked hard for it he deserves it
that's great but yeah the optics of the
the uh the situation do look like that
he was more obsessed with the hundred
million dollar number maybe than some of
the specifics like i i'm not gonna lie i
was a little surprised to see you know
hey yeah in the first three years of his
contract this is a year later he's not
going to make as much money as odell
beckham jr and some other wide receivers
so uh you know again players can get a
little obsessed with the optics of these
type of situations he's getting his
money that's the good thing and really
in all reality come on these contracts
are three-year contracts he's gonna get
three years 45 million dollars and we're
going to see how good he is at that
point and we're going to reassess and
he's going to ask for more money or the
saints are going to ask to restructure
because he's not doing good enough and
they're going to find a new way to
finagle out into a new contract that's
going to cost them less money
yeah you know with a lot of quarterback
contracts the the checks end up being
issued all the way through till the end
with a renegotiation in the last year or
two but with a guy like mike thomas by
2022 he's either gonna believe he's
getting screwed or the saints are gonna
believe they're paying him too much it's
gonna be highly unlikely the saints look
at that contract and say you know what
this guy is exactly at the level that is
acceptable to us and he's not going to
think that he should get more i mean the
market's going to change the salary
cap's going to go up and i think in
three years he may hold out again it
worked this time he may do it again but
but the the broader point is this when
you see these numbers out there
the initial reports there is good reason
to be skeptical because not only
are the agents sometimes lying to the
reporters sometimes the reporters are in
on the lie so wait a while for that true
number to begin to surface be skeptical
about it because in a lot of these cases
they're telling you what they want you
to believe and they're telling you what
they want you to tell all your friends
and they want that lie to get all the
way around the world before the truth
has even a chance to begin to pull its
undershorts and the team doesn't care
either the team likes to lie they
benefit from it they really do because
they want the guy to be happy right the
guys happy and make it gives them like
you know this false sense of where other
players around the league they're not
going to look at like you and i and look
in the nitty-gritty details of the
contract they're just going to go hey
look at the saints they're taking care
of their players they gave 100 million
dollars and that's going to go over big
with players so you know yeah the teams
are not they're they're not mad when
these like fake numbers get released
because more times or not it makes them
look better than that they they really
are
in the 18 years that i've been doing
this only one time has a team come out
and corrected the
reports that were leaked by the agent
about the value of a contract and it
happened with the raiders and receiver
javon walker and the raiders issued a
statement saying that the numbers that
were put out for javon walker's contract
were false within an hour after that the
raiders issued a statement saying oh
never mind the numbers were accurate
it's the ultimate raiders move the one
team that ever disrupts this notion that
the player got a good deal does so and
then has to say oh wait that really is
the deal sorry never mind all right i
don't even remember that that's great i
i forgot about all that
you were playing then you weren't paying
attention to that kind of stuff you were
focused on trying to uh it was probably
around 2007
ish so
uh you were dealing with all those post
spleen issues trying to get the
proprioception did i say it white
proprioception perception
did i get made fun of that
in the nfl for a little while i mean
because you know i remember writing
stories about that you were having
trouble with your body in relation to
the rest of the world because not having
that spleen was making it hard for you
to just function as an athlete yeah my
nervous system had been messed up you
know i mean they cut me down the middle
and basically just stapled me back
together and yeah things weren't firing
in the right sequence and all those
things but that's a story for another
time but uh yeah proprioception you're
very good dr florio
all right that's it for today chris
enjoy your three day weekend we'll be
back at it on monday and uh i'll be back
at it on friday
it's gonna be in and uh let's get to it
let's go do some copy paste and uh
snarky comment do it have fun no you
hadn't said that you hadn't said that
we've been you really you really are off
you haven't accused me of copy paste and
snarky comment uh yet it's it's early
i'm just trying to break you into your
groove for the season and just trying to
smooth it over we're good you're gonna
all right see you monday everybody i'll
see you friday be good
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports